marvin petit découvre la boxe à l'âge de
9 ans poussée sur le ring par son père
car trop bagarreur et commence alors
l'histoire d'amour avec les grands
pourquoi je me suis à une chasse crij
est resté dedans j'ai aimé ça et depuis
là-bas c'était ma passion j'ai je peux
plus lâcher quoi c'est en fait c'est une
drogue
à seulement 21 ans marvin petit est un
phénomène à chacun de ses combats l'élan
courtois soulève les foules
le protégé d'antoine farrugia de la
foudre à la place des points il possède
une vitesse d'exécution hors norme est
capable de terrasser ses adversaires en
quelques secondes je peux toucher sur un
coup et qui serait plus quoi mais bon
après je veux pas chercher le beaucoup
de jours moi je vais chercher à boxer
j'ai je sais que j'ai 10 2 août dans le
vente là je suis bien prêt quoi le sont
bien moralement ou mon physique je suis
un peu kamer franchement sur trois
mouvances au vainqueur du tournoi de
france et de la coupe de la ligue
marvin petit a levé les bras sur tous
les rings où il est monté mais lors de
ce combat pour la ceinture de champion
de france
il devra se méfier de l'expérimenté joël
durand à bientôt 34 ans l'actuel
champion de france des légers a remporté
17 de ses 20 combats chez les super
moyens a dit la môme à dire mettons en
jeu son titre national
l'occasion d'oublier le chapitre anglais
en octobre dernier le boxeur d'origine
comorienne avait perdu aux points face
aux champions d'europe djemdi galles une
défaite dont il a su tirer les
enseignements
conforté dans sa progression on sort
sortis plus forts parce que finalement
j'ai vu j'ai pu tenir debout face à un
mondial donc je m'aperçois site mon
niveau augmente donc ça
sa robe nude pas forcément le boxeur
élan courtois va retrouver une vieille
connaissance le cogneur tahitien cédric
bellais dernier vainqueur de la coupe de
la ligue mais surtout un adversaire qui
l'a déjà battu en 2010 le 19 janvier le
team farrugia sera donc aux affaires et
ces deux boxeurs connurent on vers un
même destin la ceinture tricolore